bon allez on éteint la lumière rouge pas
alors il a fallu dernier coup ou dernier
coup de tête
dernier coup de tête le cou tête c'est
en partant peut-être ray de la télé
ouais là les coups de poing bon bah oui
on écoute moi c'est plutôt une
engueulade en voiture
ouais avec larusso tu as les ingénieurs
honda rousseau va lancer un appel fait
pour chercher un jules tout ça on a
lancé un appel dans l'émission ça super
bien marché
personne d'annie coup de rouge en
famille pour l'île entendre dans sa
cellule au même temps et c'était le 19
janvier oh la vache à lait comment vote
soit 81 1 mètre 80 je peux pas mais ça
me complexe du complexe du petit gros
moi quand je gagne parce qu'ils n'ont
pas de fuite ou coudées un peu plus
menacé jeudi de revoir à la hausse leurs
tarifs bluff
non je suis très mauvaise même au poker
jetables et oui oui et en amour tout ça
vous ne le fait jamais non loin du pouce
cool non
bull est bizarre comme toi bien les
coups de chapeau s'est conclue question
je vous demande de ne pas répondre
franchement c'est imbécile la suivante
et mieux d'en découdre a fait mieux hier
a dit non
pour moi ils perdent toujours dans les
coups de blues
merci merci c'est une chose
avec nous c'est vous que les terres la
ville et j'accueille maintenant une
vraie médaille d'or